[Musique]
cela fait des années que j'ai envie de
passer la porte de Bercy pour en
comprendre la mécanique
pour savoir si le politique a encore un
poids face aux grands patrons industrie
dans mon métier de réalisatrice j'ai
longtemps suivi le combat d'ouvriers
pour qui Bercy et souvent l'ultime
recouvre
et puis un jour en pleine crise
industrielle et en pleine crise covit
j'ai obtenu l'accord poursuivre la
nouvelle ministre de l'Industrie Agnès
pannier runacher
le président de la République a nommé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'industrie qu'on attend aller au
cabinet
inclusive décarbonée à Lille
[Musique]
et en fait tempête je voudrais
industries ne soit pas mystère des
problèmes et le ministère des solutions
[Musique]
bonjour c'est une femme de l'ombre
bonjour on va ouvrir
donc vous dire de bêtises deux fois par
mois l'équipe bye les dossiers chaud
dans ce qu'ils appellent la war room
je découvre mur une carte de France des
entreprises en difficulté et j'ai
l'impression d'être mieux d'une équipe
de réanimation qui passe en revue ces
malades
[Musique]
en haut de la pile Alteo une usine
chimique du sud de la France ou l'État
doit trancher entre risque écologique et
risque économique
400 salariés c'est même au moins
[Musique]
ascoval Hayange
youpi
donc pourquoi on cherche pas un rachat
on va on peut se passe sur ça je pense
qu'on peut pas refaire une année où les
diplômes et puis réduit discrètement il
va rien se passer il est progressivement
et
franchement c'est qu'il nous laisse même
pas la capacité aller chercher une
solution à partir
on va bien voir soit on dit un avenir
industriel pour ce site il est pas avec
go et les essaie de le mettre sous
pression
d'une fermeture 7 ans
donc c'est de notre budget pour trouver
une solution alternative vous lâcher le
site
tu fais
ici ici on fait pas on fait on se roule
par terre monsieur
française
ok bon là je pense qu'on a fait avant
tout
notre question des inquiétudes
non
merci beaucoup
[Musique]
l'objectif de ce déplacement sur le site
ArcelorMittal Dunkerque c'est
d'illustrer de manière très concrète je
voulais décarbonation que comporte le
plan de relance
[Musique]
transition se retrouver niveau
d'activité d'avant la triste mais c'est
également d'accélérer de mener à bien
les transformations nécessaires pour
faire de la France une économie
résilient et puissante
[Musique]
le signal qu'on a une très grande
industrie en France à condition de se
serrer les coudes et te faire confiance
à nos talents.
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il va falloir
gérer des messages de restructuration
massive donc il va falloir expliquer que
malheureusement c'est ça ou la mort
lente
j'ai vu ta maman de volontarisme
c'est plutôt le contraire c'est vaut
mieux que couper la branche malade
avec l'interdiction progressive des
véhicules diesel et le basculement vers
la voiture électrique le secteur
automobile est en pleine mutation
ces mutations ne sont pas sans
conséquence le cabinet Rolland burger
mandaté par la plate-forme automobile
viens proposer un plan d'action pour les
fonderies fortement impacté
depuis quelques années les cabinets
d'audit privé sont de plus en plus
présent auprès de l'État et oriente les
futurs décision publique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un peu de courage collectif
mais ça va passer par
assumer des destructions disparition
d'un côté
sur quelques consolidateur
[Musique]
alors que vous avez prévu Renault de
supprimer
ensuite vous avez
fait pareil s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
le gouvernement les municipales
vous
de quoi parle-t-on parle d'une
entreprise qui est en grande difficulté
Renault arrive en février à l'annonce de
ces résultats en disant j'ai un plan
d'économie à faire je perds beaucoup
d'argent et j'ai une situation où j'ai
des usines qui peuvent construire plus
de 5 million de véhicule simplement le
marché n'est pas au rendez-vous donc je
ne pourrai pas les vendre
évidemment
mais est-ce que c'est d'une voiture
est-ce que c'est un moteur est-ce que
c'est d'autres activités c'est aux
industriels de nous faire les
propositions lorsque l'état fait
l'Industrie à la place de l'industriel
ça fait des catastrophes en plus
c'est un challenge et Renaud nos
entreprises françaises c'est elle qui
crée de la richesse c'est elle qui donne
de l'emploi et lorsqu'on se tient les
entreprises on soutient avant tous les
gens qui travaillent
[Musique]
une réunion avec les grands industrielle
de l'automobile se prépare et l'exercice
est complexe
comment convaincre de grand patron de
limiter de licenciement sans s'opposer à
eux
on a nos amis Renaud et nos amis de
Peugeot demain
sauf erreur de ma part avec la rupture
de composant le chômage partiel c'est
qui qui paye
capable de faire le calcul
qu'on vient chercher quand on a un
problème et se débrouille les problèmes
par contre
service aux collectifs
[Musique]
à toute
11 août
conjugal
les ministres européens font le point
sur le contrat avec le laboratoire
astra-zeneca
il y a urgence l'Europe n'a toujours pas
sécuriser son approvisionnement en
vaccin
[Musique]
on
a une
responsabilité
[Musique]
tu m'as dit que je pouvais faire qu'il
fallait que je fasse la bad girl j'ai
fait la bad girl
sur la façon de sortir élégante pour
conclure d'ailleurs ce que disent les
Italiens
il faut pas je peux pas signer n'importe
quoi mais s'il y a des points qui sont
encore trop tôt de chez tu les tu as une
rédaction les les parties se mettront
d'accord c'est bon c'est le principe
avec la meilleure bonne foi et et en
fait sur ce niveau
[Musique]
déjeuner on va faire un déplacement
social femme en région parisienne
[Musique]
donc l'objectif de séminaire c'est de
tirer les enseignements de ce que nous
avons fait plutôt pas mal
pour arriver dans une commande je vous
rappelle qu'il faut faire il faut faire
bien il faut faire savoir le
temps et cetera c'est bon la casse du
politique il y a encore une marche à
franchir elle n'est pas franchi
campagne donc la question aussi c'est la
contribution à cette campagne ça veut
dire comment on est capable de être une
plate-forme de décollage campagne
présidentielle
je suis une empathie ni les clés on doit
être à chaque fois sur chaque dossier de
reprise d'entreprise on va être capable
de en fait je veux dire c'est bon j'ai
entendu et votre truc qui vous empêche
de dormir en fait ça m'empêche de dormir
aussi j'ai pas la solution tout de suite
mais ça m'empêche de dormir aussi je
sais que c'est grave c'est grave et on
va faire quoi
aller prendre les renseignements
c'est
plutôt que je fais ce qu'ils subissent
parce que
les
autres
voilà donc la position de la ministre on
ne s'oppose pas à la loi du marché mais
on accompagne les fermetures socialement
[Musique]
c'est un nouveau coup dur pour les
autres France Bridgestone va fermer son
usine de Béthune dans le Pas-de-Calais
[Musique]
le premier moment c'est le choc et la
colère
et je sais pas
comment ça va se passer
[Musique]
Cdiscount ensemble des scénarios
économique pour se dire qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire pour avoir sur le site de
Bridgestone une production dire dans 4
ans dans 5 ans dans 6 ans elle est
toujours là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Bridgestone est un dossier test pour la
ministre elle se doit de proposer une
stratégie pour convaincre le groupe
japonais de rester sur le site de
Béthune le sauvetage de l'entreprise
repose sur un plan B conçu par un
cabinet d'audit privé
il prévoit de fabriquer des pneus plus
vendeur avec moi salarié et
d'importantes subventions publiques
[Musique]
risque
de l'ordre de 400 salariés
[Musique]
j'aimerais avant de rentrer dans le vif
du sujet salut et on disait à l'instant
la dignité des salariés sur le site
actuellement
[Musique]
il est probable qu'on a un repreneur
total sur l'activité de pneumatique
est-ce qu'on a vu se chauffer un petit
peu c'est quand même des représentants
du personnel
[Musique]
je préfère
est-ce que tu as quand même un nom jeux
pour souhaiter à l'intersyndicale à
faire comprendre et compris par votre
est-ce que il négocie super bien
il faut arriver là maintenant parce que
sinon il va mourir
[Musique]
Bridgestone refuse le plan B
jusqu'au bout les dirigeants du groupe
auront été aux abonnés absents et c'est
la ministre qui se rend à Béthune pour
annoncer la nouvelle aux syndicalistes
et à la presse
les éléments de langage sont Rodez on va
se battre certes pas pour l'emploi c'est
trop tard mais pour le meilleur plan
social possible
Bridgestone a fermé la porte Bridgestone
quitte le site de Béthune mais nous nous
serons là au côté des salariés pour
trouver les meilleures solutions
possibles
et pour que je puisse rebondir
c'est pas comprendre qu'une entreprise
pas d'accord avec le plan qu'on propose
mais pas qu'on qu'on joue au chat et à
la souris sur un sujet à 863 familles
c'est pas correct c'est juste pas
correct on est à un mois de Noël pardon
c'est pas la même chose de gérer un
dossier avant Noël et de gérer en début
d'année on a un mois avant Noël faut
quand même une petite lumière pour les
gens
qui a une somme d'argent qui est une
alternative mais faut allumer la petite
lumière il faut que ce soit clair je
crois que c'est une responsabilité
collective quand même
[Musique]
même si après si important on va moi je
crois qu'on lutte aussi pour sa fierté
qu' est-ce que on peut regarder dans une
glace en 10 heures plus tard je suis
acheté une boîte où j'ai bossé pendant
30 ans j'ai pas lutter et des années
après vous allez vous croiser dans les
magasins qu'est-ce que vous allez vous
souvenir est-ce que vous avez dire
plutôt qu'on a vécu des trucs ensemble
je sais que c'est des trucs qui peuvent
compter pour comment
mais comment se représente soi-même
[Musique]
et nous débuteront ce journal avec les
nouveaux déboires du laboratoire Astra
Zeneca ce matin Agnès pannier runacher
dans c'est que la France pourrait se
passer le son vaccin à partir du second
semaine
on en est loin
comment utiliser toutes les entreprises
dans la capacité pour produire des
vaccins ça ne se fait pas en claquant
des doigts il faut habituellement 12 à
18 mois pour réaliser ce travail la
France contre il y aura à produire des
les prochains mois 80 en France moderne
et en mars en avril Coeuret vacances et
Sanofi en juin
l'engagement de Sanofi à produire 100
million de dose
en 2021 pour Bayonne tech est un exemple
du type de coopération que nous avons
ouais j'ai mis quoi favoris accompagné
organiser
de l'Industrie
professionnel
du privé et du Vicks Habbo mission
de
faire le maximum
laisse pas comme ça je pense
[Musique]
ouais ouais ouais je pense qu'on a
par contre on peut muscler un tout petit
peu la partie commande au vaccin
c'est quoi comme tu as
raison
[Musique]
nous reviendrons sur l'annonce de la
direction de Sanofi le géant
pharmaceutique va supprimer
1701 milliers en France
4 milliards de
cette année 200 million de d'État en été
annoncée pour localiser la production
des millions des titres du crédit
d'impôt recherche est enfin un budget en
France qui dépend à 80 % de la sécurité
sociale
le plan de vaccination occupe les
esprits de la nation tout entière
comment expliquer que la France de
pasteur n'ai pas réussi à fabriquer un
vaccin et en assurer la distribution la
colère monte il faut faire vite cette
fois-ci le plan de communication devrait
être défensif
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quel est le gouvernement
la vapeur c'est ce gouvernement qui pour
la première fois
[Applaudissements]
madame la ministre
[Musique]
pourquoi on est le dernier de la classe
sur le vaccin alors série là d'abord on
a fait en 9 fois et là je parle du monde
entier. Des pays qui sont partis dans la
course du vaccin une prouesse
technologique scientifique industrielle
incroyable c'est pas si mal
il fait son job de patron et nous on a
essayé d'aller le plus vite possible
mais plus efficacement possible
[Musique]
Emmanuel kuni quel avenir pour les
fonderies avec la crise de l'automobile
la question pour plusieurs
personnes aujourd'hui
pour le PDG de Renault ce serait donc le
sens de l'histoire
le ministère de son côté avait anticiper
les difficultés à venir du secteur le
fameux rapport fonderie préconisé de se
séparer des établissements les plus
fragiles le plan est en marche il faut
mettre dans gérer la casse sociale
ça fait 2 ans qu'on le groupe c'est un
château de cartes
ça fait 2 ans pas possible
comment tu
[Musique]
je serais resté 4 minutes montre en main
dans le bureau de Bruno Le Maire
dès que la caméra s'approche du cœur du
pouvoir on nous demande gentiment de
sortir
il faut bien 3 ministres pour porter
devant les médias le plan d'action
fonderie la promesse d'une aide de 50
million d'euros. Compagnie et non pas le
maintien des entreprises mais la
reconversion des salariés licencié
il est
celui qui est le plus pour les années à
venir
nous allons donc mettre en place un plan
d'action spécifique qui doit servir de
modèle pour l'ensemble des évolutions
industriel avec un maître mot anticiper
et ne pas subir
la crise de la Fonderie française et un
révélateur
la stratégie de la ministre se heurte un
mur la loi du marché ne se soucie guère
des propositions de l'état sans pouvoir
de négociation la ministre et ses
conseillers sont coincés
[Musique]
est-ce que je peux nous envoyer un
message
[Musique]
l'étude elle te dis gentiment de deux
choses l'une soit tu accélère la
consolidation du secteur et tu reviens
avec un ticket de l'ordre de 80 million
d'euros et tu as une chance de sortir
quelques fonderie de la mousse dans
l'état des leçons toi tu les regardes
tomber les barrières les autres les unes
derrière les autres que le point de
sortie si on fait rien c'est zéro font
par exemple Poitou fonte
et à lui tu tu sortais le truc bon
c'était pareil mais ça pouvait tenir et
si nous on a pas une action très
concentré très construite très clair là
maintenant le truc c'est que c'est c'est
la grenouille qui crie dans le dans la
casserole ça veut dire elle va pas
sauter de la casserole elle va mourir à
petit feu
[Musique]
les dossiers s'accumulent sur le bureau
de la ministre
toujours dans l'automobile l'usine Bosch
à Rodez qui fabrique des injecteurs pour
moteur diesel est menacé par un plan
social Macif
vache Rodez
les annonces du vendredi 5 et quelqu'un
sera la à la Réunion faut que représente
qui va être annoncé le 5 c'est le
résultat d'un travail qui qui a été
faire en amour pour éviter une fermeture
la réalité c'est que si on n'avait pas
été morpion
c'était fermé
si tu veux et ne rien faire et anticiper
les attaques et en subir une partie mais
pas tout
je suis d'accord Nicolas mais
excuse-moi mais moi je fais la
différence
donc là il y a un problème de dossier je
suis désolé mais ça peut pas être le
côté qu'on a fait pression non personne
sait qu'on a fait pression c'est pas
vrai
et tu dis aux gens ont fait pression
mais il voit pas la menace quand tu vois
pas la menace tu vois pas les efforts
de
merde
[Musique]
je suis devant
j'aurais pu sortir par la petite porte
[Musique]
aujourd'hui il manque 11000 tonnes de
commande à fonderie de Bretagne pour
être viable les syndicats demande
l'arrêt des délocalisations un site mise
en vente par son propriétaire
qui la juge pas assez rentable
un feu chasse l'autre englué dans la
crise de la Fonderie le cabinet est la
ministre semble de plus en plus
impuissant à enrayer l'hécatombe
je pense que c'est l'objectif
désolé j'ai pas la main
faire des paroles quoi
parce que ça fait 9 mois qu'on est sur
le sujet fonderie et ça fait 19 mois non
pas de résultat si on est totalement
dans l'immobilisme économie repartira
pas elle ne repartira pas
[Musique]
une page qui se tourne à Béthune 60 ans
qui ont fabriqué des pneus dans cette
ville du Pas-de-Calais une histoire qui
prend fin aujourd'hui avec la fermeture
officielle de l'usine Bridgestone la
toute dernière fois il passe le portique
de leur usine visage fermé et Curly
on a pas fait une journée on n'a pas
volé de deux donc on a toujours été
positif sinon
[Musique]
depuis le temps qu'on dit que ça va
fermer aujourd'hui ça ferme
[Musique]
briston afficher en haut
c'est important de faire le point en ce
jour un peu particulier c'est le jour de
la fermeture de l'usine de bricks stones
sur le territoire le message clé
aujourd'hui c'est de dire une ferme mais
le travail n'est pas terminé le combat
continue nous devons accompagner
l'ensemble des salariés jusqu'au bout
dans leurs congés de reconversion et de
remplacement
[Musique]
il y en a 66 et le reste tout le monde
sait compter donne-moi le heureusement
il y a plus de 500 personnes pour
l'instant mais malheureusement c'est pas
le contraire
écouter à vous remercier et je crois que
ça me ferait très plaisir de C3 moi
d'aller prendre un café dans votre
bungalow pour voir si ça se passe bien
pour ce que c'est aussi une façon de
marquer qu'on est toujours là et comme
le dit le président région je sais j'ai
essayé de montrer qu'on est là et qu'on
est professionnel et qu'on va jusqu'au
bout
les fondeurs du Poitou sont conviés à
Bercy pour ceux qui croient être une
réunion de la dernière chance
[Musique]
impossible d'assister à cette réunion la
grille se referme devant la caméra
[Musique]
j'ai failli me donner mon choix parce
que à la fin c'était désolé on vous a
accompagné jusqu'au bout mais on s'est
fait avoir par le groupe
mon immersion à Bercy se termine en 6
que retiré de ses moi de ses crises
traverser j'ai envie de revenir vers ce
qui est un quart de l'industrie
française
je suis dans l'équipe de nuit depuis le
1er janvier 90
ça fait 31 ans que j'y suis et
malheureusement histoire va s'arrêter
mais j'aurais bien voulu encore jusqu'au
bout
[Musique]
tout ce qui vient dans sa cuisine 10 il
y a quelque chose quoi
[Musique]
et aujourd'hui tous ceux qui ont pris
cette décision d'arrêter ne peux pas
t'imaginer le mal que ça nous fait
[Musique]
je vais vous faire une confidence j'aime
l'industrie j'aime l'industrie parce que
c'est un des rares endroits au 21e
siècle mon trouve encore de la magie
[Musique]
la magie d'une idée qui devient un
produit
la magie du ballet des robots du ballet
des hommes la magie de l'atelier où on
distingue pas le cadre de l'ouvrier on
distingue pas l'apprenti de celui qui a
30 ans d'expérience
et lorsqu'on a un crochet pour rentrer
au gouvernement la stupéfaction j'ai eu
c'est la capitulation de nos politiques
depuis 30 ans sur l'industrie
[Musique]